round 10 of the US and US Women's Chess  Championships here in st. Louis  with just two rounds to go the best  players in the country came all guns  blazing in a bid for the national title  fabulous Viviano car wanna smash through  yahwah jer books defenses but it wasn't  enough to catch the superb sam Shanklin  whose win against Alexander on his truck  leaves him poised to grab his first ever  championship trophy and he wang once  again proved unbeatable as she drew an  acetone ski but that left the door open  for nasi by kid Z who kept their chances  alive with a heart pounding dramatic  wind it's the last chance for glory with  history to be made final round  action coming up next  you